يلوح بالذهاب الى بيل قرود لحمايه سكانها
في حال لم يتدخل الجيش الروسي
مقتلوا 25 مدنيا باشتباكات شمالي دارفور
بالسودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع
الصين تحذر من تحالفات شبيهه بالناتو في
جوارها ومن ان المواجهه مع امريكا ستكون
كارثه للعالم
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه تصدت انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه لغارات جويه في
السماء
لاداره العسكريه للمدينه ذكر شهود عيان ان
عاده انفجارات سمعت في نطاق العاصمه وانه
جرى اطلاق صافرات الانذار في جميع انحاء
اوكرانيا للتحذير من الغارات الجويه
اتهم قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
اتهم المسؤولين في الكرملين والجيش الروسي
بمحاوله تسليم مناطق في بيل قرود
للاوكرانيين وايضا بث الفتنه بين فايكنر
وبين المقاتلين الشيشان مؤكدا ان هذا
الخلاف قد تم تسويته الان لكن الاقتتال
الداخلي في الكلام فتح الكثير من القسمات
وصف قائد مجموعه فاجنر ما يجري في الالعاب
الخطره التي اصبحت شائعه داخل اروقه
الكرملين واعلن بريكوجين عن استيعداده
لارسال وحداته للدفاع عن منطقه الروسيه
المتاخمه لاوكرانيا مشددا على انه في حال
لم يوقف الجيش الروسي ما يحدث بالقرود
فستتدخل قوات فاجنر دون اذن
سلسله اتهامات جديده القى بها قائد فاجنر
متحدثا هذه المره عن العاب خطيره تمارسها
جهات داخل اروقه الكرملين لتدمير الدوله
الروسيه وبث الفتنه فيها
حذر وهدد من انه في حال دب الصراع بين
فاجنر والقوات الشيشانيه فان الرابح محسوم
لكن سينتج عنه حمام دم كما قال
صدقني لو حصلت مواجهه بين قوات فاجنر
وقوات اخماط الشيشانيه سيكون النصر لنا
لكن سيؤدي ذلك الى اراقه الكثير من الدماء
فصائل مجهوله من داخل الكرملين اتهمها
بريكوجين بفتح صندوق بندوره لزرع
الانقسامات على حد وصفه
ليؤكد من جديد على ان الخلاف القديم مع
المقاتلين الشيشان قد تم تسويته بالفعل
الخلاف بيننا وبين المقاتلين الشيشان قد
تم تسويته لكن الاقتتال الداخلي في
الكريملين فتح صندوق بندوره من الانقسامات
عاصفه من الاتهامات اللاذعه شانها قائد
فاجنر على وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايضا بعد
ان تعرضت منطقه بيلجرود في الايام الاخيره
لقصف وهجمات مكثفه
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما يحدث
في منطقه بيل جرود حيث يتم الاستيلاء على
اراضي روسيه فمن الواضح اننا سنتدخل ولن
ننتظر دعوه او اثنان للانتشار في المنطقه
اثار الشد والجذب المستمران بين قائد قوه
فاغنر والنخب الروسيه تساؤلات عده بشان
طبيعه العلاقه بين الكرملين والمجموعه
العسكريه الخاصه
وسط ضبابيه العلاقه بين الجانبين
اعلنت سلطاته مدينه كان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه حاول تنفيذه هجوما صاروخيا على
المدينه لكن انظمه الدفاع الجوي تمكنت من
اسقاط سته الصواريخ كانت قوات الاوكرانيه
قصفت امس ميناء بيرد جانيس كالمطل على بحر
ازوف ما تسبب بخسائر ماديه في الميناء
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مصادر
استخباراتيه امريكيه قولها ان مهاجمي
مقاطعه
الماضي استخدموا اسلحه ومركبات غربيه منحت
لاوكرانيا اوضحت المصادر ان الاستخدام غير
المقصود لاسلحه حلف الناتو المقدمه
لاوكرانيا في هجمات ضد الاراضي الروسيه
يثير قلقا غربيا
تميزت الحرب في اوكرانيا منذ بدايتها
باستخدام المسيرات بجميع انواعها الهجوميه
وتلك التي تستخدم في التجسس وحتى المدنيه
التي تم تحويلها لاهداف عسكريه تريد انتاج
اعداد كبيره منها لاستخدامها في حربها مع
روسيا
حرب المسيرات هكذا يصف المراقبون الصراع
الدائره في اوكرانيا وعلى هذا الاساس وجهت
كييف قدراتها للحصول على هذا السلاح باكبر
كميه ممكنه 200 الف هذا عدد المسيرات التي
تسعى الحكومه الاوكرانيه لشرائها بحلول
نهايه العام هذا الكم الضخم سيتم انتاجه
محليا حيث ان 30 شركه محليه تنتج المسيرات
المطلوبه وقد تم توقيع عقود مبدئيه لفي
وحده لاسابيع قليله حيث تتم زياده الاعداد
المطلوبه كل فتره هناك حاجه الى المسيرات
بكل انواعها وبقدرات مختلفه من اجهزه
الاتصالات كلما زاد عدد المسيرات التي في
حوزتنا زادت قنوات الاتصال وبذلك يصبح
عملنا اكثر كفاءه
الاوكرانيون يستخدمون مسيراتهم داخل
اراضهم للدفاع ولكن كذلك للهجوم
حيث استخدموا الطائرات بدون طيار لضرب
محطه السكي لتكرير النفط في منطقه كوبانا
المسيرات تسمح لقوات كييف بالحاق الضرر
بروسيا فقد وصلت الى الكرملين في هجوم لم
يلحق ضررا كبيرا بمقر الرئاسه الروسيه
ولكنه شكل ضربه قاسيه للدب الروسي امام
انظار العالم
انس نماسي العربيه
افادت مصادر العربيه بين الشبكات دارت بين
الجيش السوداني ودعم السريع شمالي دارفور
ادت لمقتل 25 شخصا بشكل موازن افادت مصادر
سودانيه بوفاه شخصين الى ثلاثه يوميا في
مدينه الجنينه غرب ولايه دارفور بسبب
انهيار القطاع الصحي والاوضاع الانسانيه
الصعبه هناك كشفت مصادر عن وجود عدد من
القناصه في المدينه وسط انباء عنيه جماعات
مسلحه بالسيطره على مدينه الجنينه
نتواجد اليوم هنا في المواصلات الخاصه
بمدينه بولايه شرق دارفور غربي السودان
بعد انقطاع اكثر من 36 مدينه باقليم
دارفور عن الاتصالات اصبح لا سبيل
للمواطنين في الحصول على الاخبار سوى
الوصول الى هذه المواقف والاسواق بغرض
تتبع ما يدور في بعض الولايات فشبكات
الاتصالات في غرب دارفور وفي
وسط دارفور منقطعه تماما وهنالك ايضا عدد
من محليات اقليم دارفور لا توجد بها
اتصالات والله من عيد رمضان ولهذا الان
الشبكه الرابعه
دي كلها الشبكه قاطعه ما قادرين نتواصل مع
نحن
كل المناطق لحد الجنينه
قاضي
كل المناطق
ما في اتصالات بعد
الانقطاع الكبير في الاتصالات شكل عائق في
الحصول على الاخبار بالنسبه للصحفيين
والذين يعملون في المواقع ووكالات الانباء
المختلفه هنا باقليم دارفور حيث يمثل
السوق هو المكان الوحيد للحصول على هذه
الاخبار التي قد تاتي قديمه ويمر عليها
اكثر من يوم بسبب انقطاع الاتصالات وعدم
الحصول على تغطيه كافيه في عدد من المناطق
الساخنه باقليم دارفور والتي دارت فيها
معارك ودار فيها قتال الايام الماضيه
لو حتى الان يعني بيجيني خطابات من
الولايات مختلفه رغم انه شبكه توقفت
والتواصل
يعني وقعدت بتجينا خطابات ورسائل في مختلف
الولايات حتى الان اصحابهم قادرين يوصلوا
عليها ورغم انه الشبكه يعني مين الشبكه ما
وقفت لحد الليله
الناس بقت ترجع لموضوع الخطابات الزمان
تقول بعض شركات الاتصالات العامله هنا في
اقليم دارفور ان ابرز ما يواجهها من
تحديات هو التحدي الامني بنسبه للعاملين
في هذه الشركات كما ان عمليه الحصول على
الوقود الذي ياتي من الخرطوم يمثل تحدي
كبير لعمل هذه الشركات باقليمي دارفور
صالح ابو علامه لقناته العربيه والحدث
اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن
تشكيله حكوميه جديده شملت وزارتي الدفاع
والخارجيه هينا اردوغان رئيس
الاستخباراتها كان في دان وزيرا للخارجيه
ورئيس اركان الجيش التركيه شارغولر وزيرا
للدفاع
عبر الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الى ولايته
الرئاسيه الثالثه بانتخابات لم تكن سهله
اضطر فيها للذهاب الى جوله اعاده ولايه
ثالثه يتعهد فيها صاحب اطول فتره حكم في
تركيا بصياغه دستور جديد والمضي نحو ما
يسميه قرن تركيا في الذكرى المئويه الاولى
لتاسيس الجمهوريه
سنعزز ديمقراطيتنا بدستور جديد حر ومدني
وشامل ونتحرر من الدستور الحالي الذي كان
ثمره الانقلاب عسكري
تشكيله الحكومه الجديده وكما كان متوقعا
حملت وجوها جديده بالكامل لم يستعن
اردووان بوزراء حكومته السابقه باستثناء
وزير الصحه فخر الدين كوجا ووزير الثقافه
والسياحه محمد نوري ار سوي وعين اردوغان
جوده نائما للرئيس وهو الذي شغل مناصب
حزبيه وحكوميه عديده ابرزها وزاره التنميه
الوزاره الاهم في ظل تضخم غير مسبوق تشهده
تركيا هي الماليه والخزانه حيث عاد
الاقتصادي المرموق محمد شمشك لشغل هذا
المنصب مجددا وزاره الخارجيه كانت لرئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات هاكانفيدان والداخليه
لوالي اسطنبول علي ييرلكايا اما الدفاع
فكانت لرئيس اركان الجيش
مراقبون يرون ان تعيينات وزيري الخارجيه
والدفاع انما هي استكمال لنهج انقره في
العامين الماضيين استكمال الانفتاح في
السياسات الخارجيه ومحاوله العوده الى
سياسه تصفير المشاكل والبقاء على نفس
النهج فيما يخص السياسات العسكريه لتركيا
بالنسبه لها كانفيدان يمكننا ان نقول انه
يعني احسن
تعين لهذا المنصب وزاره الخارجيه يمكننا
ان نقول اذا
لو ينجح في هذا المنصب
ويدير امور الوزاره الخارجيه لمصلحه تركيا
ولمصلحه الرئيس اردوغان يمكننا ان نقول هو
ولي العهد لاردوغان في المستقبل القادم
وفق ما اكده الرئيس التركي فان الاجتماع
الاول للحكومه سيكون يوم الثلاثاء القادم
في ظل تحديات داخليه لا يخفى على احد ان
الاقتصاد وخفض التضخم هو العنوان الابرز
لها
ربما من المبكر القول ان اردوغان وحزبه
بداوا الاستعداد للانتخابات المحليه
المقبله لكن التغييرات الكبيره في الحكومه
والبرلمان تشي بان الرئيس اطلق فعلا حملته
للاستحقاق الانتخابي القادم في محاوله
استعاده البلديات الكبرى التي فقدها في
الانتخابات البلديه الماضيه ونتحدث هنا عن
انقره واسطنبول على وجه التحديد زيدان
زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
نتنياهو يصف الحادث على الحدود المصريه
بالخطير وغير العادي ويتعهد بالتحقيق فيه
حتى النهايه
اهلا بكم من جديد حضر وزير الدفاع الصيني
لشانغ فو امام قمه حوار الامنيه في
سنغافوره حذر من اقامه تحالفات عسكريه
شبيهه بحلف شمال الاطلسي في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ قائلا انها ستغرق المنطقه
في دوامه من الصراع كما اعتبر المسؤول
العسكري الصيني ان المواجهه بين بلاده
وامريكا ستكون كارثه لا يمكن للعالم ان
يتحملها
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو من الحادثه المميت على الحدود
المصريه خطير وغير عادي وسنحقق فيه حتى
النهايه اشار نتنياهو لان التحقيق في
الحادث جاري بالتعاون الكامل مع مصر لكنه
اكد انه لن يؤثر على التعاون المشترك الذي
يشمل حفظ الامن على الحدود بين البلدين
جاء ذلك بعد مقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
واصابه اخر في حادث امني على الحدود مع
مصر كما اعلن عن تحديد مطلق النار
الجيش المصري من جهته اعلن عن مقتل عنصر
امن باطلاق نار اثناء مطاردته لمهربي
مخدرات على الحدود مع اسرائيل قال المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الجيش المصري ان عنصر الامن
اضطر لاختراق الحاجز الاسرائيلي اثناء
عمليه المطارده قبل ان يفارق الحياه خلال
تبادل لاطلاق النار
معبر العوجه
بين اسرائيل ومصر انشئ عام
1982 عقب معاهده السلام بين اسرائيل ومصر
على بعد اربعين كيلو مترا من نقطه التقاء
الحدود الاسرائيليه المصريه شرق رفح
استخدم في بدايته معبر للمسافرين
والمركبات يستخدم حاليا لاستيراد البضائع
من مصر الى اسرائيل او قطاع غزه عام 2012
بنى اسرائيل سياجا امنيا على طول الحدود
بطول 241
كيلومترابا على البحر الاحمر حتى نقطه
التقاء الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه
نوفمبر 2022 تاريخ اخر محاولات تسلل
شهدتها الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه قتل
خلالها احد المهربين
السادس من يونيو 2023 مقتل ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين على الحدود مع مصر
مصادر العربيه كشفت عن اتصالات المصريه
اسرائيليه اجريت بهدف عقد اجتماع الامني
العاجل بشان اطلاق النار على الحدود بين
البلدين اضافت مصادر العربيه انه تم تشكيل
لجنه مصريه اسرائيليه بشان حادث اطلاق
النار على الحدود تكراره
اصدر 61 عضوا في البرلمان الليبي بيانا
يتهم لجنه سته زائد سته بتجاوز صلاحياتها
بعد زياده عدد مقاعد البرلمان طلب اعضاء
البرلمان في بيانهم اعضاء اللجنه الالتزام
بمهامهم حول نقاط الخلافيه فقط المتعلقه
بعمليه انتخاب الرئيس وعدم الموافقه على
اي تعديلات لا تتم تحت قبه البرلمان كانت
وسائل الاعلام ليبيه ذكرت ان اعضاء لجنه
سته زائد سته صوه بالموافقه بالاجماع على
قوانين الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
وقع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على قانون
رفع سقف الدين العام الامريكي الامر الذي
يجنب الولايات المتحده التخلف عن سداد
ديونها ما كان سيؤدي الانهيار اقتصادي وفق
خبراء غربي
على حافه انهيار اقتصادي بدت الولايات
المتحده بل والعالم بسبب سقف الدين
الامريكي الذي تم حل ازمته قبيل وقوع
الكارثه سقف الدين هو قانون يحد من المبلغ
الاجمالي للاموال التي يمكن للحكومه
اقتراضها لدفع فواترها وفي الحاله
الامريكيه فلا يمكن للحكومه تخطي مستوى
سقف الدين الذي حدده الكونجرس فيما يسمح
توقيع الاتفاق لحل الازمه لواشنطن بتفادي
التخلف عن سداد مستحقاتها
والسماح للحكومه باقتراض المزيد من
الاموال كما يشمل دفع تكاليف الموظفين
الفيدراليين والجيش والضمان الاجتماعي
والرعايه الطبيه بالاضافه الى الفائده على
الديون الوطنيه والضرائب المسترده وابعاد
الخطر عن الشركات والمؤسسات الخيريه التي
تعتمد على الاموال الحكوميه
الاتفاق يمنح الفرص لتفادي اخطار متعدده
منها انخفاض اسعار الاسهم بمقدار الخمس
تقريبا وانكماش الاقتصاد باكثر من اربعه
في المئه كما جنب البلاد فقدان سبعه
ملايين موظف لعملهم وعلى المدى الطويل كان
الخطر سيحيط بالديون الامريكيه ما يدفع
بالمستثمرين لفرض فوائد اكبر على واشنطن
لاقتراض الاموال لينتقل التاثير لبقيه
الاقتصاد فيصبح شراء سياره او منزل عبر
الاقتراض اكثر تكلفه للجميع
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الشرطه السويسريه انها تحقق في هجوم
الكتروني استهدف مؤسسات حكوميه في الدوله
من بينها قواته شرطه الكانتونات والجيش
السويسري اكدت السلطات انها فتحت تحقيقا
لمعرفه ملابسات عمليه القرصنه التي طالت
انها
انتقد وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي واوصفه
بالاستفزاز الصاروخي غير المسبوق من كوريا
الشماليه قال ان كوريا الشماليه هي الدوله
الوحيده التي تهدد بضرب دوله معينه بشكل
استبقي باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه مشددا
انها ينتهك القانون الدولي اضاف وزير
الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه ان بعض الدول
تتغاضى عن هذا التهديد
في اكثر حوادث السكك الحديديه دمويه
بالهند منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات وفقا لوكاله
روترز اسفر تصادم ثلاثه قطارات في ولايه
اوديشا عن مجزره جماعيه
[موسيقى]
في اليمن وتحديدا مارب سجلت حمى الضنك في
اوساط النازحين هذا العام ارقاما كبيره
رصد مستشفى الوحده بمنطقه الحصون شرق مارب
اكثر من 100 حاله خلال الايام الماضيه في
ظل جهودا حكوميه محدوده ومناشدات لسرعه
تدخل المنظمات الدوليه لمسانده القطاع
الصحي في محاصره الوباء
بعد مواسم الامطار يكون التوقيت السنوي
لانتشار حمى الضنك في مخيمات النازحين
بمارب قد بدا فعليا بالظهور الوباء
ظهر هذا العام سريع الانتشار محطما
الارقام السنويه المسجله في المشافي
الحكوميه
القنوات حق السد منال
المخيم كامل امراض حمى
تروح البيوت عاد فيها امراض عظم من
المستشفى بلغ عدد الحالات الى امس 71 حاله
مصابين بحمى الضنك هذا بسبب المستنقعات
المائيه الموجوده اضافه الى طفح بيارات
الصرف الصحي والى سائله الموجوده هنا
امامكم التي ممتلئه بالقمامه نساء واطفال
واسر بكاملها تتردد على مستشفى الوحده
بمنطقه الحصون شرقي المدينه بحثا عن
العلاج يقدم لهم المستشفى خدماته
بامكانياته وكادر محدود بعد اصابه خمسه
وسبعين في المئه من العاملين الصحيين فيه
بحمى الضنك
انتشر في مسبح الحصون بشكل كبير ومخيف حيث
اصبحنا في مستشفى واحده بالحصول نستقبل
اعداد هائله من المرضى ما يقدر ب 15 حاله
الى عشرين حاله في اليوم في عشر ايام
الاخيره استقبلنا من قرب 95 حاله مستشفى
الحصول كادرها اصيب اصيب بنسبه 75%
السلطات الصحيه بمئرب بدات خطوات توعويه
لمحاصره الوباء اضافه الى نزول الفرق
الميدانيه في مناطق الانتشار بهدف تكثيف
التوعيه بضروره التخلص من المياه الراكده
والخزانات المكشوفه وكل مصادر البعوض
الناقل لحمى الضنك اوجدنا فرق في الميدان
من متطوعات وعاملين صحيين للتثقيف في
المديريه وايضا في منطقه الحصون بالاخص
وايضا ان شاء الله في حمله ستقام به حمله
الرش الضبابي مع غياب الوعي الصحي وسوء
الخدمات ومكان الماوى تتضاعف معاناه
النازحين سنويا مع حمى الضنك في كل مخيمات
النازحين تنتشر حمى الضنك وفي المخيمات
القريبه من مرور مياه قنوات الري تتزايد
هذه الحالات في ظل وضع صحي كارثي محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
في نهايه نشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
يلوح بالذهاب الى بالقرود لحمايه سكانها
في حال لم يتدخل الجيش الروسي
مقتل 25 مدنيا باشتباكات شمالي دارفور
بالسودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع
الصين تحذر من تحالفات شبيهه بالناتو في
جوارها ومن ان المواجهه مع الولايات
المتحده ستكون كارثه للعالم
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات